tens of thousands of people are expected
to take to the streets of glasgow today
in a global day of action against
climate change
the teenage activist greta tunberg will
address climate campaigners as the first
week of cop 26 draws to an end millions
more will protest in other towns and
cities across the world they want
leaders to act now to prevent a climate
catastrophe
ashley hurinag reports from glasgow
they're up for a fight on an
international scale their armory pieces
of cloth and plenty of paint
the night before is spent at this
warehouse where protesters are
empowering one another before the big
day georgina has traveled from london
especially
we're obviously at cop26 so if that in
itself doesn't tell you that these past
policies that have been created even
though they've been great in theory have
not been practically applied in the
correct way
and they don't want to wait any longer
the last week of cop has been
really really disappointing and that's
coming from someone who didn't have high
expectations to begin with it has gone
out of its own way to exclude climate
activists especially
young people from countries around the
world um especially people of color as
well and those who are suffering the
worst effects of the climate crisis
already
this disappointment partly echoed by the
young activists who marched through the
city yesterday
in some respects they're good pledges
are they enough and will we see the
action um
i'm not sure young people are banging
the drums they're saying you might not
listen to us but we're going to make our
voices heard
thousands joined greta toonberg and
other key climate figures as they took
over the city from saving the bees to
planting more trees messages everywhere
from those like eight-year-old cameron
mine
says
if not you who
if not know when cop 26
act no
and why do you feel it's important that
you guys are here today to join all the
other people in protesters
if we don't act no then our planet could
be in
real danger
from climate finance to deforestation to
the indigenous communities to the
impending catastrophe everybody here has
their own reason for being here there
have been so many protests throughout
this week
this one today though is going to be so
much bigger 100 000 people are pounding
the pavements
and that's just in glasgow today is a
global day of action
the voices outside could well overshadow
the conversations inside as discussions
of cop 26 turn to protecting the natural
world if this rallying of the troops is
anything to go by their urgency reveals
they believe their time is now
ashna haranak sky news in glasgow
well overnight we've also seen protests
from climate activists across other
parts of the world including australia
where some think the prime minister
scott morrison is holding back on
committing to change but as siobhan
robbins explains the prospect of wiping
out fossil fuel is not something that
everyone agrees with
hundreds of protesters have taken to the
streets of sydney today to demand
immediate action on climate change they
want full renewable power by 2030 they
want an end to coal power they want
pledges on methane and there's also been
a protest going on in melbourne as well
lots of disappointment here from
australia's actions so far at cop26 of
course australia didn't join that pledge
to cut methane they also haven't been
among the countries pledging to move
away from coal power but it's a very
different message in communities like
this one i'm in the upper hunter valley
in new south wales in one of the coal
mining communities there are mines
dotting the landscape around me this is
the main uh train line which carries the
coal through the state and when i've
been speaking to people here involved in
the industry they say well it brings us
really good jobs we've got great wages
they invest in the community we don't
think we need to be moving away from
coal for 20 to 30 to even 50 years in
the future they are very determined to
carry on the message coming out of these
communities is if people around the
world want coal australia will sell it
bosses at five of the uk's largest
supermarkets have promised to halve the
environmental impact of a weekly shop by
the end of the decade tesco sainsbury
waitrose the co-op and m s have all
agreed to work with the worldwide fund
for nature to reduce the impact they
each have on the environment well let's
talk to our correspondent ender brady
and how are they planning to do this
ender well steven there are four key
sectors that they will actively look at
and work towards reducing their impact
on now the food sector itself is
responsible for some 30
of global climate emissions so this is a
very significant agreement the sectors
they're going to look at food waste and
packaging the impact on agriculture and
seafood
forestry being cut down and global
warming itself so we've got the chief
executives of tesco sainsbury's waitrose
co-op and marx and spencer that
together between the five of them they
have effectively half of the uk food
market so it's a very significant
agreement they're going to work with the
worldwide fund for nature we've got
statement through from their chief
executive tanya steele she's hailing
this as a game changer she says the
promises these ceos have made are game
changing and we hope other food
retailers will follow in their footsteps
so that every shopper can be confident
the products they buy are not fueling
the climate crisis and pushing precious
wildlife closer to the brink and as i
say the food sector responsible for some
30 of total climate emissions so a very
significant deal reached between five
major british retailers this morning
okay ender thank you
well after a torrid few days for the
government dealing with the fallout from
the owen patterson lobbying scandal it's
turning its attention back to climate
change the uk
leading the call for an urgent global
shift to a more sustainable way of
farming to protect nature our political
correspondent rob powell is in
westminster for us i mean is this the
prime minister trying to get back on the
front foot rob yeah i think so and
labour though clearly trying to still
inflict some damage on this sleaze row
calling for investigations now
into boris johnson himself and over that
refurbishment of
the downing street flat of his downing
street flat and also for an
investigation as well into a holiday he
took earlier this year to spain that was
paid for by
one of his ministers lord goldsmith a
billionaire minister i think it would
have been a disappointing few days for
boris johnson after a sort of
tentatively hopeful start to the cop 26
um summit um in glasgow it has been
pretty much completely overshadowed the
last few days by this sleaze row today
what the government wants to talk about
is nature
and land nature and land day in glasgow
so we can expect pledges from
governments around the world uh on
shifts to a more sustainable way of
farming and land use now farming
of course makes up a huge part um of the
climate
problem in terms of emissions both in
terms of cows and methane but also
deforestation land being cleared um for
farming around the world as well um i
think the broader issues the government
will face and perhaps the criticism they
will face today um on this is to begin
with i think you will hear from a lot of
environmentalists that say that this is
merely tinkering around the edges
and for as long as there is demand
for meat for dairy then there will be
demand for
farming for food production that
ultimately damages um the climate i
think also as well you get back to this
tension
of um
between richer countries essentially
asking poorer countries to do less of
things that make them more money and
that raises the question of okay what
sort of compensation what sort of money
is going to flow from richer countries
to poorer countries to help them to do
this now today the uk government is
announcing various allocations towards
research
towards more sustainable farming but
also
just aid money to go towards countries
to help them farm in a greener way
as well but of course that is set
against the context of richer countries
missing that hundred billion dollar a
year target in climate finance and also
the uk as a country um lowering the
amount it gives in international aid in
the last year or so
okay rob thank you
well for uninterrupted coverage of the
summit including special guests and
analysis you can watch sky news climate
live on channel 525 and sky glass
channel 505
now people in england will be able to
book covid 19 booster jabs a month
earlier under a change that takes effect
on monday and as we head into the winter
months there has been a major
breakthrough in the fight against
coronavirus fisa developing an antiviral
which could cut hospitalization and
death by up to 89 let's talk to
professor of virology university college
london a member of independent sage dean
and pillay good to see you this morning
i mean actually this isn't this isn't a
new drug is it this is um one that's
being repurposed
uh no there's two drugs that have
recently
come come on stream one is
monopiria a bit of a
mouthful
which is a specific antiviral which
itself has been developed previously
against other viruses but in fact has
not been used clinically and widely um
so that's one and the other is one that
uh so far we've just seen the press uh
release from pfizer uh for and we await
mhra approval but of course this is is
good news um to develop antivirals i
should just say in the context of of
this that there are two phases of covet
infection the early phase where of
course you get infected with the virus
and the virus replicates in your throat
and nose and and lungs um and
many many people of course recover from
that but the the the difficulty in that
the hospitalizations and severe symptoms
and unfortunately death is due to the
immune response against that virus um
and therefore many of the successful
drugs so far um have been developed to
damp down that immune system things like
dexamethasone a steroid whereas these
drugs um are against the virus and
therefore need to be used very early on
in the disease process in order to have
effect
but in that sense that's positive is it
because it means presumably that people
are going to become less infectious as a
result
there'll be less transmission
that's absolutely right and and
so it's a great advance but there is a
big caveat here is that in order for
these drugs to be effective they
therefore need to be used very early on
in the disease process um within three
to five days of initial symptoms
and if we then um think about what the
logic of
of that it means then that individuals
as soon as they get symptoms to be
tested and if they're found to be
covered positive by pcr something that
may take some some time days
then they need to have access to the
drugs immediately these are um tablets
so they're not injections they need to
have access to those drugs very soon in
order for them to have effect and for
that reason there's a lot of work now
going on and other trials in the uk to
work out precisely how best this can be
used in practice because of course it
once people get into hospital that is
too late for these drugs to be used so
it becomes a more of a health systems
challenge about how best to use these
effectively and to target them against
for people who are particularly high
risk of getting severe um outcomes from
their infections see it's interesting
isn't it because when we we have this
approach and it's understandable where
we sort of think if if if there's a
medication
we relax a little bit but this is a such
an effective medication but we need to
be on higher guard as well so it's a
case of of us testing i guess more
frequently or or you know not ignoring
the slightest symptom for this all to
work
oh absolutely and and and it's of course
no no replacement for vaccination which
by is is if we look at individual
interventions is by far the most
effective um way to prevent um being
infected and transmit that infection and
of course we're in the mo in the process
at the moment of um of severe challenges
to the nhs there's been well publicized
stresses on primary care general
practice so the idea that you would test
positive
and then just ring up your gp to get a
prescription to then go and pick it up
at the pharmacist is clearly not going
to be the model to maximize the use of
of this this drug but i i completely
agree and it's important to stress that
that by far the most effective thing
that we can be doing um as individuals
is to have our vaccination make sure
we've had double vaccination where
eligible
have the third dose as a booster and of
course young people who are eligible to
have vaccination now should have those
um uh so that that remains the important
way to prevent spread of infection
just briefly in terms of the booster
what difference you think it'll make the
fact that people could now book in
advance we've got to wait six months
after the second booster but the fact
you can now book it a month in advance
is that going to get more people on
board i really hope so i mean we know
that the initial vaccine rollout was
hugely successful and that was almost
so totally due to um
primary care throwing their weight
behind this and having a lot of people
working volunteering to provide vaccines
now of course the boosted program has
not been going so well um young people
being being immunized is not going so
well um which is also a reflection of
the the stress of primary care but also
a bit more of a confused a bit more of a
mixed way of providing the boost so i
think any any ways to make this easy um
should be encouraged and and i i would i
would urge the government to go further
um i think they need to invest primary
care is a good basis for doing this
because everyone has has a primary care
physician everyone has a general
practice but of course more money needs
to be going in to support that at this
time when there's increasing stress on
the health service
dealing pillow good to talk to you thank
you thank you
well two hyenas at denver zoo in the u.s
have tested positive for coronavirus the
first confirmed cases amongst the
animals worldwide samples from a variety
of animals at the zoo included the
spotted hyenas were tested after several
lions at the facility became ill zoo
officials said the hyenas 23 year old
kibo that you see here and 22 year old
ngozi are experiencing mild symptoms
including slight lethargy
some nasal discharge and an occasional
cough
that's what i've caught at the minute in
addition the two hyenas 11 lions and two
tigers at the zoo also tested positive
for the virus all animals that are
tested positive have either fully
recovered or are expected to fully
recover
twelve people have been arrested after
hundreds of anti-establishment
protesters gathered in trafalgar square
demonstrators wearing guy fawkes masks
then made their way to parliament square
and burned an effigy of the prime
minister the protest is held every fifth
of november
on bonfire night
the u.s house of representatives has
voted to pass a 1 trillion bill that
will see major improvements the nation's
infrastructure this includes a
rebuilding of roads and bridges the
modernization of public works systems
and a boost to broadband the white house
projects the investments will add on
average about 2 million jobs a year over
the coming decade
now yorkshire county cricket club says
it will do whatever it takes to tackle
racism that's a promise from the club's
new chairman hours after his predecessor
resigned following days of criticism
over the way the club handled
allegations of racist behavior two other
board members have also stepped down
more sponsors have withdrawn their
support and the bbc has announced it was
dropping former england captain michael
vaughan from one of its shows next week
after he became drawn into the rail
salia choudhary has been speaking to
cricketers in yorkshire about what the
sport needs to do moving forward
it's tough in these nets
where amateur cricket players practice
even in the off season
but if asian youngsters thought things
get better at the top
this week gave them a taste of what may
come at them i'm from yorkshire so
representing yorkshire would be a big
part of
a cricketing career but
yeah
now since that story has come out i find
it hard to really represent i feel like
although other people from other
other backgrounds will be um considered
before before and i think that uh we
have to be much better for them
much better than other people to be
selected when you hear things like this
maybe
you know
yeah it gives you a wider view of
reality and say
you might not have the same
opportunities
the future of the country's cricket
talent lie in places like this
youngsters who live and breathe the
sport but allegations of racism at one
of england's most historic clubs have
left many doubting their chances
sky news has spoken to british asian
cricketers in all levels of the game who
say they're put off playing for
yorkshire none of them wanted to come on
camera because they say the industry as
a whole isn't the kind of place where
you can speak openly about your
experiences
it seems a long time ago that england's
diverse world cup winners helped boost
the game's profile with 10 000 more
fixtures played in adult recreational
cricket this year than when england
lifted that trophy
grassroots coaches say racism at
yorkshire looks set to unravel all that
it unlocks all the good work that we've
been doing for decades and it takes us
back
to an era where
racism was rife but we've been making so
much progress so this sort of incident
takes us back to that unfortunate era
for yorkshire crickey remember it was
not that long ago where yorkshire had a
policy unless you were born in yorkshire
you could play for yorkshire
whenever yorkshire play here at
headingley stadium they can count on a
big contingent of fans from an asian
background
but today they're expected to
demonstrate against the club in
solidarity with azeem rafiq
[Applause]
in these nets hours of practice are
meant to pay off but after this week's
revelations young players may need some
convincing
sadia chowdhury sky news in yorkshire
just want to bring you some breaking
news this morning about a situation in
texas where officials say at least eight
people have died and a number of other
people have been injured after there was
a crowd surge during a travis scott
concert at the astro world festival
in houston it happened about nine
o'clock local time last night travis
scott is if you don't know is a rapper
um the fire chief saying the the crowd
um
surged towards the stage while travis
scott was performing that the show was
called off as you can imagine but eight
people are confirmed to have died and
several others have been injured at the
astro world festival as we get more
details through
we will of course let you know
okay let's have a look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well unsettled weather returns to the
country this weekend it replaces the
cold northerly flow that we've had with
some slightly milder conditions so wet
start in the north and west winds
freshening at the gales over western
scotland elsewhere largely dry but
rather cloudy
rain will spread across much of scotland
north west england and wales by
lunchtime central southern and south
eastern parts breezy with some bright
sunny spells
let's just remind you of the breaking
news this morning and officials in texas
say at least eight people are dead and
several others have been injured in a
crowd surge at the astroworld music
festival houston's fire chief told
reporters it took place while travis
scott the rapper was performing the show
was called off shortly afterwards
now yorkshire county cricket club says
it's going to do whatever it takes to
tackle racism that's a promise from the
club's new chairman hours after his
predecessor resigned following days of
criticism over the way the club handled
allegations of racist behavior let's
talk to community cricket campaigner
abdul ravat good to see you this morning
i mean it's interesting isn't it that
roger hutton who resigned yesterday said
in his statement you know he'd been he'd
been pushing for change he'd been trying
to get something done but but
unsuccessfully so which is why he he
took the fall for this i mean do you do
you think we are starting to see some
change then
i think so i mean the genie is out of
the bottle there is no hiding place for
such behavior and such conduct and so
therefore lord patel i think has got a
very difficult task in front of him but
if there's anybody who can actually
tackle this and repurpose and recover
from this position then the lord propel
has got the set of skills are needed
exactly at the moment but not just not
just for yorkshire but for also qrikey
as a whole
are you surprised at any of this because
i mean i think a lot of us i mean i i'm
no cricket fan particularly but you know
we're very much aware that there's you
know there is a strong asian presence in
the game i mean i was really surprised
to hear that there was you know still
these levels of racism
that are i mean not even just under the
surface that are breaking through
well the reality of recreational cricket
is a third of all the crooked plane in
this country is from the south asian
community but then when you distill that
down to
facilities investment governance
officials that number unfortunately is
lacking so that's where the disparity is
between you know the the
representation and participation
and where the decision-making process
has happened so what we need to do now
is make sure that there is that
representation and there's inclusivity
in the decision making because
ultimately if we don't make the right
decision if if there isn't that
diversity of thoughts and thinking
regards to that then then nothing's
going to change isn't it
i mean it does seem extraordinary that
that
you know a panel found or upheld you
know a number of these complaints i
think it was six or seven but decided
not to take
any action i mean
there has to be a shift in focus doesn't
there from you know protecting the club
to protecting the player
well let's look at it from a governance
point of view how does it look when an
independent investigation finds seven of
the 43 um
allegations of hell and the the you know
that the previous chair apologizes but
the institution of york security fails
to act upon that that's just not good
narrative is it in any book so
unfortunately the the the tipping point
i think in terms of public perception
and in terms of how this has escalated
is that an issue so then you've got to
wonder the decision making process
behind that you're going to think about
the risk
management process in relation to that
and why wasn't anybody asking you know
what the implications would be so when
you when you do the postmortem on this
you know the risk analysis the risk
mitigation the risk control all of that
unfortunately is lacking
um i mean obviously we're hearing that
the the the equality and human rights
commission are getting involved in in
this now and
and asking for further details from
yorkshire county cricket club i mean
the fact that this is
you know making having this sort of
impact is is this going to be a good
thing for the whole game
well i think the the issue here is that
you know we cannot isolate crickey from
wider society so there's a systematic
issue here around racism and subtleties
around islamophobia as part of that and
i think the issue is particularly on the
back of the black lives matters a
movement people aren't going to tolerate
this and and
actually for example what we've seen
from the sponsors they're not going to
tolerate because it doesn't look good
for them so you know that's going to
have a massive reputational impact for
yorkshire and crickey as a whole because
we need yorkshire yorkshire is a global
cricket brand we have now quickly
growing all across the world and we
can't tolerate this sort of behavior so
the issue now is that it's going to hurt
when it really hurts in terms of the
bottom line but if that if that if that
then means that cultural change happens
in the county within the game and wider
society then that's got to be a good
thing and i i i i you have to applaud
asim rafiq's you know um
coming forward and the the personal
stress and the and the mental stress
that he will go under as well as you
know people in in yorkshire cricket who
i know and are doing some sterling work
but the thing is enough is enough
i mean you you deal with it with a lot
of young people
in in the work that you do i mean what
impact does that have on them that these
young people who who
you know dream of of playing in the in
the big time
well you know people when they see
mowing alley when they see ideal russia
they're icons not just for the south
asian communities but for the whole
community as a whole but when they see
things like this they'll think well is
it a game for us are these institutions
organization going to represent our
values gonna re gonna kind of sort of
support our values and and what you've
got is that whole talent potentially
being lost because they will they will
not feel comfortable so the net loss of
that is is quickly in england
and are competitiveness in the global
game
abdul ravik really good to talk to you
this morning thank you
thank you
it's time to take through the papers
once again with the journalists for the
guardian and vice freddie mcconnell and
the editor of nottinghamshire live
natalie fahey good to see you both once
again natalie let's start with the
telegraph should we in these changes to
booking your booster
yeah well obviously this seems like a
quite good news and there's been
complaints that the booster roll out has
been particularly sluggish so
good news that 10 million more people
over the age of 50
excuse me can book their booster vaccine
from monday
now the change to me seems actually
quite small and apparently it's that
before you could book a week after your
six month anniversary of the vaccine
now you can pre-book your appointment
after your five-month anniversary so
they're hoping that 10 million more
people will get this before christmas
now obviously there's been quite a lot
of good news about covid and the new
pills that's coming out
uh which apparently have an 89
success rate in cutting covid so um
you know we'll see how things go over
the next few months but i think one
thing we can say for certainty with
kovid is that nothing is ever certain
no no that's that's very true though i
have to say someone who's been trying to
book my booster it's um it i think it
will be easier now that i know from
monday i will be able to book it because
i don't know when the exact date of my
you know when i'm actually due but i
will be able to get on the system which
is quite encouraging um to the mail
freddie looking at the the migrant
crisis which is ongoing
yeah it's extremely concerning so
yesterday was uh it was a record number
of arrivals of migrants from calais in
small boats of um
853 in total in one day
and then sort of uh beside that you have
a just an angry war of words between
government officials on both sides of
the channel accusing each other of not
caring um emmanuel macron accused of
focusing too much on the fishing boat
dispute and not enough on
you know
people literally
dying either trying to cross or as one
eritrean migrant was killed by after
being hit by a train this week
um
so it's just uh i mean i've read
elsewhere actually that there's no there
haven't been any pushbacks um
from the uk side which i think for
anyone following this story from a kind
of humanitarian perspective is a sort of
small mercy and i live um
just across uh down the coast from dover
and we actually saw the uh border force
practicing pushbacks a few weeks ago
which was a pretty shocking sight so
just knowing that that's not happening
um at the moment when obviously it's
very cold and very dangerous time of
year to be crossing the channel um i
mean i suppose it's something but yeah
seeking sanctuary which is a non-profit
um is quoted in the piece saying that
the governments really just need to work
together to keep people safer which
should be a no-brainer one would think
but
yeah yeah
i mean it's all it is
well ongoing and ramping up so it would
seem um natalie to the mail and
something which i mean i i
i can't tell you how abhorrent i find it
particularly with my 18 year old niece
just starting at
uni in the last month or so
this this whole issue with spiking
now is
is just seems to be getting out of
control everyone is of that age and you
know is just so aware of what's going on
yeah i mean and it's difficult to know
where exactly the problem lies um i mean
the daily mail says this is a special
investigation but to be honest i'm not
surprised at all that you can buy these
drugs on the internet
so the mail is saying you can buy
rehypno and ghb on the internet with
express next day delivery which
obviously those drugs are well known for
being used in nightclubs and spiking in
spiking incidents
now whether it doesn't make it clear in
this piece whether or not
those pieces are going those drugs are
going to be used to spike drinks or
whether they're going to be used putting
needles to spike women because it is
mostly women that are being attacked
here
because we are seeing a rise in
incidence of women just sort of being
jabbed with needles which is just
absolutely atrocious and and so
terrifying are nightclubs safe anymore
for women we just wonder don't we
it's just i i can't imagine how people
are able to get hold of these drugs so
easily though i mean who's selling them
online i mean it's absolutely illegal to
sell that sort of stuff isn't it
yeah well it doesn't specify who's
selling them online obviously but it
worried me that you can get them so
cheaply the price of 20 pounds was
mentioned there i mean you know we're
talking small amounts of cash here to do
absolutely great damage to
young women in nightclubs um
what what can women do there's a case
study there mentioned and
something we're feeling particularly
keenly and nothing at the moment because
that was where the first reports of this
sort of needle spiking emerged from and
we spoke to women in the city who said
they just started wearing leather
jackets on nights out and denim jackets
because they felt they were less likely
to get jab by needle is it really right
that women have to change their behavior
in this way just because of this sort of
thing that you can buy you know with
next day delivery on the internet
terrible no i mean the answer to that is
is no but then i guess
from a sort of uncle point of view you
just said do what do whatever you have
to do to stay safe at the moment but
it's it's it's just the most disgusting
situation
um freddie to the mirror um
looking at obviously with the the
environmental stuff at the moment and
melting glaciers which uh i mean it's
it's a it's a depressing sight with a a
depressing view to the
future yeah so this is a sort of uh
small piece focusing on one particular
activist um a peruvian activist who's 25
called innocent bar
who has uh come over for cop 26 to talk
about the fact that i suppose she spends
a lot of her time on the front line as
an activist in her home country um
trying to prevent or slow the loss of
glaciers she says in the past 40 years
that peru has lost 22 percent of its
glaciers and she uh she mentions this
well she says the phrase past the mic
which is interesting i've heard that in
other contexts i know that when sir
david attenborough was announced that he
was going to retire his
instagram account which has over 6
million followers
um
young activists like ines called on him
to quote pass the mic with a hashtag to
um to give that audience to two
frontline young activists around the
world i don't think that's happened
um
but it's interesting to see that phrase
mentioned here and i just can't imagine
how difficult it must be for someone
like ines to know what's happening back
home and
you know maybe she was wondering
should you know
do all these activists is it a good use
of their time to be flying over to
glasgow you know when they uh
they're spoken about in some quite
patronizing and disparaging ways by by
sort of senior politicians
it must just be um
infuriating to be honest yeah well no
it's a good point though um natalie
let's have a look at the the guardian
and children's diet fitness and mood in
the pandemic and no surprise it's it's
not very good reading
yeah i wasn't surprised at all to read
this it's really upsetting actually and
uh you know this is one of the effects
of lockdown and the pandemic that we're
going to be seeing more of these aren't
we over the coming weeks months years
decades there's going to be report after
report on the effects but
children you know i think all of us can
agree that they've been really badly
affected by this the closure of schools
not able to see the friends
and the sort of division between the
people who have got laptops and access
to food deliveries and all those kinds
of things at home and those who haven't
had really become stark and the
guardians saying here that 25 27 sorry
percent of children aged 10 to 11 said
they suffered significant emotional
difficulties
i mean you've also got to think about
you know the conversations around the
dinner table it's unavoidable how does
that affect children they're worried
about their grandparents
they're worried about their parents
they're worried about friends teachers
at school we've got covid and
you know
it's a dreadful situation there's no
doubt look thanks both